[Music]
on this wednesday night
another allegation of sexual misconduct
in the military
people do not understand the breadth and
depth of the problem
why one top officer says she has to quit
a global news exclusive interview and
another exclusive
how the rcmp reportedly ignored
harassment complaints against an alleged
spy
the abhorrent mistreatment of another
indigenous patient in quebec
the two nurses accused of racist
behavior
and green with envy hopefully this is
the last year that we're going to have
to do st
patrick's day this way another st
paddy's day
in the pandemic
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
she is among the top ranks of the
canadian military
and tonight lieutenant colonel eleanor
taylor is speaking exclusively to global
news
about her decision to quit in a powerful
one-on-one interview with our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson
taylor explains how disgust over
allegations of sexual misconduct
at the highest level drove her away and
fueled her hope
to make a difference i felt that
perhaps i might be able to
add to some of the momentum here by
signaling my disappointment
and forcing people to recognize the cost
of failing to address this issue
taylor has formally requested her
release from the canadian armed forces
as soon as possible
as mercedes stephenson reports it
appears they will be tough shoes to fill
it was a tour of constant contact with
the enemy
patrols gun fights ambushes
and deadly roadside bombs my company in
afghanistan
was a remarkable group of people
lieutenant colonel eleanor taylor
led her troops and made canadian history
the first woman to command
an infantry company in war that wasn't
the only glass ceiling taylor would
shatter
jtf2 canada's most elite and secretive
special forces unit
spotted and recruited taylor where she
would lead the unit's vancouver olympics
preparations
on international women's day taylor
resigned from the military
i felt that the most powerful thing that
i could do
in uniform was to leave it taking a
stand
in frustration disgust and despair over
allegations of sexual misconduct by
military leaders
and the brass's failure to address the
systemic problem in the forces
to find that senior leadership
is not living the example that
they expect of us it cut the legs out
from under everybody
the breach of trust with the troops was
devastating
but not surprising i was hearing this
undercurrent
and feeling this undercurrent of
seething rage
from within the women and other victims
in the organization
for people who live in this organization
this type of behavior is no surprise
in the days that followed global news
reporting of alleged sexual misconduct
at the highest levels of the canadian
forces taylor experienced
deafening institutional silence and
internal conversations that revealed
some senior leaders
did not believe the problem was real or
take it seriously
the attitude was bunker down and hope it
all blows over
there are people who are saying
troops don't care this is an ottawa
problem
that for me was the true
indicator that we really don't
understand this problem
so lieutenant colonel eleanor taylor is
taking off the uniform she loves
once again leading trying to protect the
troops who she commands
by sacrificing her own career taylor
says the military
will need outside help to change i do
not think that the military can fix this
on its own we need to leverage experts
from outside
our organization we have demonstrated
quite resoundingly
that we cannot fix this on our own
lieutenant colonel eleanor taylor has
been invited to speak to army council
that is the most
senior army leadership that meets here
in ottawa
part of what she wants to raise with
them robin changing the military's
culture
mercedes has there been any response
from the military or the defense
minister
well what's really struck me about this
story has been the unofficial response
from the military and it's been
resounding and like nothing i've ever
seen in almost two decades
of covering that institution i have
heard from men and women of all ranks
who say that
eleanor taylor was somebody who they
profoundly respected
and that her decision to resign in
disdain over what is happening
has really made them rethink how serious
this problem might be
in the forces and reckon with it
meanwhile defense minister harjit sajin
says he's committed to creating a safe
work environment for everyone on the
defense team
saying all options are on the table but
the opposition is criticizing the
government
the ndp laying the blame for this
directly at the government's feet
and saying the prime minister must
change the system now
before more women like lieutenant
colonel eleanor taylor are forced out of
their careers
tomorrow we're going to hear more from
lieutenant colonel eleanor taylor
about deeply upsetting incidents of
sexual misconduct in the canadian forces
and why women haven't been reporting it
that the consequences of coming forward
can be worse than suffering in silence
robin
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes global news has uncovered
exclusive details about an independent
review into an rcmp unit
while it was being run by a suspected
mole in 2016
cameron ortiz was hand-picked to lead
the force's national intelligence
coordination center
in 2019 he was arrested and charged with
preparing to share secrets with a
foreign entity
none of the allegations has been proven
just months into his leadership role
employees were complaining to rcmp
leadership
about harassment and a toxic work
environment but as david aigan explains
the review found those complaints were
ignored until it was too late
after the rcmp's cameron ortiz was
arrested in 2019 on
charges of offering up police secrets to
an unknown foreign entity
the rcmp ordered a review of the unit he
headed the national
intelligence coordination center the
nicc
is home to the rcmp's top counter spies
and intelligence analysts
a clearinghouse of the most top secret
information
held by the national police force that
review is now complete
and while it has not yet been made
public global news has obtained a
partially censored copy of the report
it paints a picture of a toxic workplace
where harassment and
demeaning comments were common from the
time orders took over the unit in 2016.
former rcmp superintendent angela
workman stark
reviewed the version of the report
provided to global news
i think another aspect that stood out
for me was this real lack of
accountability in the sense of no one
took ownership
of the issue and saw that these
complaints were addressed in some
fashion
the report describes how morale among
the country's top intelligence analysts
had hit rock bottom
yet rcmp management ignored multiple
complaints from employees
we were ignored completely once said it
was a terrible negative environment
said another all our careers were harmed
and so on
the refuse authors interviewed nearly 50
who worked under orders or with his unit
anybody reading the report could
understand those very
human implications for the individuals
in terms of all those quotes that were
highlighted in the report i think that
was that was important
some of those analysts are now suing the
federal government saying among other
things that
the rcmp's failure to look into their
complaints
may have allowed ortiz to continue to do
the spying he is now accused of
in the meantime the rcmp said in a
statement that
it is working to address the findings in
the review
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
we have breaking news on the case of the
two michaels
the chinese government will put them on
trial on accusations of spying
starting this week in a statement
foreign affairs minister mark garneau
says our embassy in beijing has been
notified that
court hearings for michael spavor and
michael kovrick are scheduled to take
place on march 19
and march 22nd respectively the two men
were arrested in december 2018
days after huawei executive mong wong
zhou was detained at vancouver's airport
on a u.s extradition request their
arrest is widely viewed
as an act of retaliation if you use
microsoft exchange for email you may
have been affected by a recent cyber
attack called
deer cry the hack was extensive but as
abigail beeman explains
we may not know whether any canadian
organizations have been hit
because they're not required to report
it to the government
we've been alerting to this for the last
two weeks and we need the systems
updated
the canadian center for cyber security
is warning about a ransomware attack to
microsoft exchange called
dear cry microsoft issued a security
update two weeks ago
the head of the cyber center says they
know of canadian systems still
vulnerable
your organization is not patched by now
you should seriously consider whether
your organization should be running its
own information technology no canadian
company has reported a hack yet but
that's no comfort
they're also not compelled to do so
given the worldwide level of
exploitation
and the number of systems that we are
seeing reported in canada
or the the different systems that we're
seeing unpatched systems in canada
it's very probable in fact it's almost
certain
that there will be victims in canada
people who have
on-premise microsoft exchange servers
should absolutely be worried
cyber security expert yuan stevens says
it's a problem we don't know the extent
of the issue here
people can contact the administrators
and the i.t
teams of the organizations they're
working at and i think they should
absolutely check in with those it
professionals to figure out is their
data safe cyber criminals are getting a
lot more greedy
a new ransomware threat report shows the
highest demand from attackers doubled in
2020
to 30 million dollars and in the year of
the pandemic the most
targeted sector healthcare if they can
shut down their
entire data management system inside the
network they can prevent that hospital
from
you know seeing patients from performing
surgeries according to that report in
terms of countries that had stolen data
published online
across the globe canada ranked number
two
after the u.s abigail beeman global news
ottawa there are questions tonight about
the effectiveness of canada's covet
alert app
the app was launched last summer as a
tool to help alert canadians to
potential exposures
but it appears so few people have used
it that it's had little effect
new public health data shows only 3.8
percent of about 535
000 people who tested positive after the
app went live
have used it to warn others the number
of people testing positive for highly
contagious new variants is climbing in
canada
according to the federal public health
agency more than 4
000 variant cases have now been
confirmed
most are the b117 variant first
identified in the uk
the bulk of the cases are in bc alberta
ontario
and quebec on the vaccination front
there is slow
but steady progress over the last five
days on average
about 110 000 doses were given out per
day
and momentum is picking up across the
country today the city of toronto opened
its
three mass immunization clinics for now
appointments are available only for
people 80 and over
about 450 people are expected to be
vaccinated per day
the city says it plans to ramp up
operations
when there's more supply quebec's health
care system is once again facing
allegations of racism
after an indigenous woman came forward
with her story of mistreatment
it happened in the same health authority
where joyce eshequan
died in september eshequan had used her
phone to record the racism she faced
from hospital staff
there was no recording this time but as
mike armstrong reports
management appears to have had no
trouble proving it was true
it's mr humiliation
is the word she uses jocelyn ottawa says
that's what she felt after visiting a
clinic
where the staff was supposed to make her
feel better
it happened here last friday ottawa went
in for a treatment to one of her feet
and says the nurses she met
intimidated and mocked her now
she says one of the master if she could
sing a song in a ticamac her indigenous
language
then one joked she had taken ottawa's
phone to steal her personal information
and then there was a joke about her
first name jocelyn
the unknown she says when one of the
nurses saw her name in the file
she said they'd call her joyce whatever
apparently being a reference to joyce
eshequan the atikumek woman who died in
hospital in september
37 year old recorded her last moments
before dying
staff at the hospital could be heard in
the background calling her stupid
as hell and only good for sex both
eshequan's incident
and ottawa's were in the same town under
the same
regional health authority the regional
health board confirms it was informed of
the incident monday
and opened an investigation immediately
by tuesday morning
both nurses involved were suspended by
tuesday afternoon
both were fired in a written statement
the board's president says the
organization has a zero tolerance
policy towards racism quote the comments
of the two fired employees demonstrate a
breach of the code of ethics of the
nursing profession and the code of
ethics and
values of the organization those actions
and situations are unacceptable well the
government is also investigating another
incident a job posting last fall at this
hospital is raising concerns
it was open to white-skinned candidates
only
the staff was apparently having trouble
with a patient suffering from dementia
who could be violent towards visible
minorities there are
questions whether the intent was racist
but the posting did
violate the rights of employees who
could not apply
due to the color of their skin mike
armstrong global news
joliet quebec asian women
targets of a murderous spree in atlanta
coming up
why police don't believe this was a hate
crime
in the u.s eight people were killed in a
shooting rampage
six of the victims are asian-american
women a suspect is now charged in their
murders and as jackson proskow explains
there are questions about whether this
attack was a hate crime
in less than an hour three shootings
targeted three atlanta area spas
unfolding in rapid succession while at
that location we received another call
across the street at shots fire
of the eight people killed seven are
women and six are asian-american
the suspect 21-year-old robert aaron
long was arrested late tuesday
identified by his parents after police
released surveillance footage
yesterday was a really bad day for him
and this is what he did despite the
targeted nature of the attack
police were quick to downplay any
suggestion of a hate crime
based on what they say the suspect told
them he
apparently has an issue what he
considers a sex
fiction he sees them as an outlet for
him that some things that he shouldn't
be doing
and that an issue with porn and that
he was attempting to take out that
temptation but the context is
inescapable
according to the group stop aapi hate
asian americans have reported being the
victims of at least 3 800
separate hate crimes in the u.s during
the past year
some deadly a crime against any
community
is a crime against us all the rhetoric
from former president donald trump about
the origins of the pandemic
china virus coincided with the rise in
race-based attacks which continued to
this day
but knowing the the increasing level of
hate crime against our asian american
brothers and sisters we also want to
speak out in
solidarity with them police say the
suspect in atlanta not only admitted to
carrying out the shootings
but may have planned to drive to florida
to carry out more attacks
whatever his motive his alleged actions
have left the community already on edge
reeling jackson cross go global news
washington
the irish band u2 took a trip back in
time for st patrick's day
kicking up a virtual tour they
re-released this homecoming concert from
2001.
we're back in a moment
[Music]
canada says iran's final report on the
downing of ukraine airlines flight 752
is incomplete iran's civil aviation
authority blames human error repeating
what the country's military said when
the jet was shot down in january 2020
all 176 crew and passengers were killed
including 138 people with ties to canada
the canadian government has the report
and says it makes no attempt to answer
critical questions
about what truly happened ottawa plans
to release the results
of its own investigation a symbolic
victory tonight for same-sex couples in
japan
a district court has ruled the
government's ban on same-sex marriages
is unconstitutional this is japan's
first ruling on the legality of same-sex
unions
it has no immediate effect but it is
expected to bolster efforts for
legalization
japan's constitution defines marriage as
one of mutual consent about
sexes same-sex couples have no parental
rights to any children
and can't inherit their partner's assets
japan is the only g7 nation that doesn't
fully
recognize same-sex partnerships
twice unlucky up next st patrick's day
jigs don't jive with the pandemic
in honor of saint patty's day folks in
dublin were treated to aerial artistry
more than 500 drones synchronized to
form shamrocks and celtic art
the orchestra of lights was produced to
offer some hope and happiness to people
in ireland
and around the world this is the second
year in a row that the annual parade
had to be cancelled bars and pubs in
canada
aren't feeling the luck of the irish
again this year
many establishments are facing
restrictions on the number of customers
or limits on how late they can serve
alcohol
some aren't open at all missing out on
one of the biggest days of the year
so celebrations may be muted but as
heather york's west explains
a year into the pandemic some
festivities are forging ahead
kovid or not the owner of calgary's tool
shed brewing company is buzzing with
excitement
he even bought a slushie machine so you
don't necessarily
just need guinness we've got a great
stout with irish whiskey slush on top
with physically distanced tables and
limits on capacity the celebration this
year
will be muted in bc last call happens
at 8. with all the restrictions the
owners of the old
triangle irish ale house in halifax
decided not to bother
when we sat back and looked at it and
with redu you know social distancing we
wouldn't have it wouldn't have even been
as profitable as normal and we said you
know
it would be a lot of work for for what
would be a tainted patrick's day
in parts of ontario pubs remain closed
for irish-born shawn o'shea it's been
hard
they canceled christmas i had to cancel
my wedding um but one of the hardest to
hit was the cancellation of st patrick's
day because
it's uh such a big day and such a big
celebration the best way to
celebrate is virtually at home uh that
is absolutely true
and uh hopefully this is the last year
that we're we're going to have to do st
patrick's day this way but it is
certainly a necessity given where we are
in the pandemics
we've all become accustomed to adapting
holidays to covet restrictions
but this year st patrick's day has the
distinct honor
of becoming one of the first
celebrations to be touched by kovid
twice it was one year ago that bars
across the country first went
dark with no way of knowing how long it
would be before people would be able to
gather
again but with vaccines rolling out we
can finally see
at the end of the rainbow there really
is a pot of gold
people are really excited they see the
light on the horizon
and there will be plenty to celebrate
next year
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with a tune and a
view for this st patrick's day
chalice patrick dexter put on an
open-air show on ireland's west coast
his lockdown concerts have gone viral
during the pandemic
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]